Britney Spears reveals she's a big fan
of Khloe Kardashian's glam
and Coco's reacting we all want to be
cute over here okay the Pop Princess
praise the reality star's look from
Beyonce's birthday party in September
tweeting she's the reason I crimp my
hair now how effing hot is that but I
don't see how hers is more puffy I'm
working on it she's beautiful
[Music]
Coco responded but gave all the credit
to her Glam Squad quote you are so sweet
I wish I could say I did this myself but
I did not ha I believe it was done with
a curling iron then we combed it out
sort of back combed it for volume and
used texturizing spray sounds like a lot
you're beautiful it's a beautiful thing
and Chloe's big sis Kim couldn't agree
more when it comes to Coco's Beauty she
replied to the singer's tweet she sure
is Bible it's a great look but Kim's not
the only one Her Mama dear Kris Jenner
feels the same way I'm proud of my kids
on their family reality show the
Kardashians Chloe expresses interest in
getting some plastic surgery I'm really
contemplating getting my boobs done and
at one point Mama Chris was even down to
get them done with her it's just
something oh let's do it together
okay is that weird mother-daughter boob
jobs
but the mom of six quickly did a 180. oh
boy this is what I want all the time
I'm gonna have a consultation since
consultation for what chichis no Mom I
listen it's a consultation no okay
you're perfect the way you are Chloe
thank you Mommy thank you
implant Road and it's not always I'm not
doing a Pam Anderson situation
well whether Coco decides to change her
look no matter what she has a fan in
Britney Spears
[Music]
[Music]